he is a super bowl-winning head coach
with the Pittsburgh Steelers and
currently one of the top analysts in the
game for CBS Sports the NFL today and
his football life premieres tonight at
8:00 p.m. Eastern on NFL Network he is
Bill Cowher how are you coach I'm doing
great I'm hanging in there right now
coach so what did you think of the
Steelers 52 point destruction last night
they got 52 points most points that
they've had for a Pittsburgh team since
quite some time predating you even yeah
I know I got after the first drive that
Cam Newton right down the field you
thought wow okay that was pretty
impressive with their first play unless
you just played the play-by-play
Smith Shuster catches that bomb and and
then in next very next play cancer the
Pick six so you know I tell you it's a
very good Pittsburgh team I think when
you look at and the one thing that you
have to say is they're getting better
defensively they can put pressure on the
quarterback without a question
TJ watt cam to bud Dupree eyes I think
offensively just the people that have
emerged you talk about from James Conner
the year he's had but I really liked it
to other parts of that is Vance McDonald
and Switzer I think they give them
elements of a tight end of a slot
receiver that Ben has really not had in
the recent past so I there's a lot of
weapons on offense Ben is very
comfortable in command of that offense
and offenses can put up at least 30
points a game and I think the defense is
getting better and they're they're
playing very well right now well coach
moments ago I started the show to say
look you know they do have a lot of
weapons and they're gonna get one back I
mean Le'Veon Bell is coming back and I'm
assuming at some point he is gonna be
suiting up and on the field for the
Steelers and you know as much as
Steelers fans might be upset with them
and whatever might be going on in the
locker room can get smoothed over I mean
putting him at a two running back set
what James Connor is gonna open up even
more of the stuff that you said right
now I'm wondering what you think about
the levy on bail return and if you do
think he is going to in fact step on the
field for the Steelers this year I think
he will return why do you go back to
Pittsburgh North to return at the
he'll return by 4 o'clock next Tuesday I
think at that point the scrutiny will be
on him number one
what kind of shape is he when he walks
into the building what is his attitude
like in a more importantly you know what
is his mannerisms on the field the
scrutiny is going to be there but you're
going to get a player if he does come
back and he wants to play as you said
it's like getting one of the best free
agents if I'm with the all the free
agents that were signed at the end of
the the trade deadline this the best one
to be able to get you're talking about
getting a backup to James Carter who's
want to top running back to the leg and
we know it levy on Bella's down over a
period of time so it's another weapon
for Ben it's an insurance policy to
secure the running game and but again
the bottom line will be what are you
getting when he walks into the building
I think they'll take him with open arms
I think everybody the teammates will and
I think the first time you scored that
touchdown we're all going to forget
about all the things that took place
before focusing on where you are now and
more importantly moving forward but I
also could not help but notice in your
comment right there Bill Cowher that you
called him a backup to James Conner is
that how you would handle it as coach of
the Pittsburgh Steelers absolutely I
think the James Conner has earned this
you know ones absence I've always said
this before you don't lose your job to
injury but you just create an
opportunity for someone else or someone
else ceases that then you have to wait
for your opportunity so I would just say
to me that you have two running backs
they have them both healthy going to the
playoffs I certainly would be starting
James Conner and I would certainly be
using levy on bail so I would like keep
them both fresh particularly for the
month of December January so I don't
think James Carter has done anything to
lose this job I think as the levy on
bail comes in he's not entitled to
anything other than an opportunity to
play on this team what do you think of
the coaching job Tomlin's done this year
I guess been very good I think mike has
navigated way through some you know
everyone talks about the drama in
Pittsburgh but I I know the building
well enough to know that the drama was a
lot more louder on the outside and it
was on the inside they've got very good
leadership in there Ben is really
matured and I think it'll kind of deep
as a side of law you know the one guy
that keeps getting look over elder look
as Kim Hayworth he's the cap
you saw last night in two sacks two
decals were lost they got some good
youth there Jill Hayden's have a Pro
Bowl year again so you know the
offensive line the other one talks about
everything on the weapons but they I
think they also have rich the best
offensive line of football so they're
healthy they're experienced they've got
weapons um and I think Mike has done a
good job just keeping everybody kind of
focused and after a rocky start but I
think they're playing well anybody right
now well I'm sure we'll see a little bit
more in the football life later tonight
about the Roethlisberger arrival in
Pittsburgh and obviously the Super Bowl
that you guys won in Detroit waving
goodbye to the bus and you also but
before we get to that what you just said
Ben Roethlisberger has matured how is
Roethlisberger now different grown man
kids wife etc outside of that your jorb
from the kid yet you you met from Miami
of Ohio bill you know opportunity to see
some of the conversations we even had a
subsequent to me leaving and he was he
was a kid that came in that had a lot
going for him a lot of people that
supported him I kind of got tough on him
in shows and tough love early but you
know at this point though he is the
piece the leader of that football team
he knows it he's in command of that
offense these are what it has to keep
everybody happy he understands the rule
of the quarterback and you know he's
playing at a very high level and night
you know I watch them and I just you can
just hear them in his voice he's just
got a great perspective on life he's in
a great place it appears and it just you
can just see it and you know he's the
leader he keeps everybody going
he keeps their you know key of like kind
of even keel along the way and you know
he orchestrates that you know he do 3
1-3 incompletions last night so he's
playing well keeps everybody involved in
the game he's got some you know Antonio
can be keeping Tonio happy but you keep
on Antonio happy he produces for you so
I just like where he's at in terms of
his leadership again on that side of the
ball and then defensively guys talked
about Joe Haden cam Haywood there's they
got good leadership throughout that team
what do you take out of the night for
the Panthers bill well III I like the
cam
I like cams take on it like listen we
may listen you had one of those nights
anything it could go wrong went wrong
I'm starting with his first pick six but
I'd still like that team I think the
only questions I have is probably on the
defensive side of the ball
I think offensively I think you're
looking at a pretty special player and
Christian McCaffrey I just think he is
dynamic and you watched him last night
and I think getting Samuel you got speed
now that you have not had one god
right I mean you've got a lot of people
right now that I think are that you're
surprised around and can with I think
he's playing well his completion
percentage of drunk he's thinking less
sexy I got sacked five times last night
so I like where there are again their
defense is going to secondaries young
you'd like to think you're going to get
better as the season goes on but you
know I you know Luke Kuechly lot of best
inside linebackers in national football
league I think it was just one of those
nights I wouldn't over-read it I think
though we have a chance to look at it
reflect on it but you know this
schedules going to come down to play in
New Orleans to the last three weeks of
this season and there will be the
defining moment all right let's talk
let's reflect now football life tonight
at 8:00 Eastern Time I'm assuming again
from you talking about previewing the
tough love conversations you had with
Ben you have seen the hour-long program
you've seen him yet coach I okay and
what do you think well I had a box of
tissues next to me my life and I did so
in his some pretty moving moments
honestly rich I think what you're going
to see as a journey that I had
Pittsburgh that was reflective of my
players and family I had on the field
but more importantly my the women I had
off the field that was a part of my that
journey and I just think you're hearing
the reflection through the eyes so my
kids some of the players some of the
coaches that were with me along the way
molded who I was and I think it's a
journey that was well told by NFL Films
John ways I thought it did a fantastic
job and just put into looking at it for
the proper perspective you know it was
all the people that were with me through
the course of that that a 15 year
journey and I think the proper
perspective was placed on good
which is the ones are with you through
the good times in the bad that's your
family and we experience a lot of good
times we experience a lot of tough times
but at the same time it was nothing did
nothing but make our family stronger it
has just kind of neat to see the
perspective years later you know I say
how many times you have a chance to
reflect a little bit it's nice to see
what and hear other people talking about
you as well so it really did for me it
was um it just brought some closure to a
great career and and how it was depicted
I thought was excellent alright before
we get to the closure part
Schottenheimer i assume is in there too
right you were part of the the Marty
staff yeah Marty was yeah Marty as I
said in the piece oh I'm nothing what a
reflection on Laurie shot timer that's
the only coach I ever coached under and
he taught me so much about preparation
and you know how to to break down and
the work ethic that takes from coaching
perspective to be able to communicate to
players and he was he was the ultimate
person in terms of leaving no stone
unturned and in terms of leaving the
game behind as you say closure there is
a job opening Cleveland coach and
there's some people there that would you
know might think look you know that
you'd like to get back in it that not no
coach is ever totally out of it are you
totally totally out of the idea of
coaching again I said a piece I said why
close a window or a door that you don't
have to um I don't know where I'll be
two or three years from now I don't know
if I'll get the itch you know I don't
know my wife Veronica would you know
she's kind of been a part of this
football they have brought her along and
you seen her on the Thursday night yes
learned she's with us and she's given to
music and you know our family is so
close and so I doubt it to be honest
with you I have a great platform I
really love the balance in my life and
know what it would take to go back into
it you have to delve yourself into it
they're gonna be you know 70 hour weeks
and you you have to if you want change
the culture you got to be a part of that
change you got to be there every day so
if I ever did it I would understand the
commitment but I can say right now I'm
in a good place
great balance and
life and and when you watch a show
tonight it really was about my 15 years
of Pittsburgh and how lucky I was and
how blessed I was to be surrounded by
the people I had and the journey was was
a very fulfilling one well in terms of
getting your mind right and family right
that's one thing about returning do you
in even in your mind have a concept of
what it would require in terms of
quarterback in place roster in place
owner in place is that it even something
that you've figured out mentally to
potentially I think you'd have to get
you got to that point and you're
thinking about coaching again and I
think again any any situation you have
it's going to be unique and I think part
of any job of any new coach is trying to
look at it understand the dynamic that
you're walking into in terms of what the
decision-making process is in that
building understand what you need to
prioritize in terms of what you want to
build certainly a quarterback is the key
to anything that is sustainable in the
National Football League and some people
have won some people may not have won
but it doesn't mean when you look at
these college kids coming out now there
are some very exciting prospects that
are out there so you know listen up for
many years I was playing with some some
good quarterbacks I wouldn't say great
meaning from the old Donald to Kordell
Stewart to Mike tomczak to tommy maddox
and then all sudden then came along and
then was pretty special you knew that
but you know it took a bad year to get
them to pick up in the 12th picking
address and sometimes people don't are
able to survive that so and sometimes
it's just being in the right place at
the right time and having the
opportunity to get him you know we have
to be 12 in a class that have Eli throw
rivers and then it's a pretty good class
and so other classes have not produced
the same kind of talent so so it's all
unique I mean the quarterbacks important
but you can still win in the National
Football League and change your culture
with making sure all the other elements
are in place until that guy comes along
all right last one for you then pretty
special guy in Kansas City right now
after you suit you've seen what
Pittsburgh is now what it could possibly
be if as we've supposed the levee on
bail return goes smoothly
and then there's the goat in New England
how do you see the AFC playing out as
we're currently sitting here one game
into week ten coach I again would just I
think the word that you have them with
me honestly I think I think I go Kansas
City New England and and Pittsburgh at
this point again I think Hong field has
a lot to do with it I think villains
have to be at home so is Kansas City so
is Pittsburgh without all those games
could they go in the world and win no
question about it
the only other team I would say that
don't don't lose sign up right now with
LA Chargers the la tour has been playing
on the road for like a year and a half
now
academic I mean they even they play at
home and since they like its home game
so but they are playing very well and I
think if they get to playoffs
Philip Rivers Melvin Gordon if they get
bozer back with Ingram I'm telling you
be careful don't overlook this LA
Chargers well coach I really appreciate
the time look forward to checking on the
football life you deserve it I've
cherished our Thursday nights that you
referred to hanging out with you and
Queen V in the in the green room with
the rest of the CBS gang so best to your
wife and your family and I'll be I'll be
checking it out tonight thanks rich
always enjoyed talking to you my friend
right back at you that's Bill Cowher the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience